Oh my god I'm going to make something besides piss.
Oh god.  Is my body even going to be able to drink this not piss? (No clue.)
Oh, I don't know about this whole disinfected water bull shit.
I'm paranoid enough to keep on drinking my own piss until the end of my days.
It's the only thing I know is safe. Cause I made it right out of my body.
Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now in this episode, I'm going to be doing probably the dumbest thing I've ever done in all of Subnatica, and something I'm not looking forward to very much.
But it all has to do with this comment by ChillieMathew here. Who gave me a bunch of good ideas but
one of them above all else and it seems plausible because a lot of these are really good ideas.
But one of the things says that if I offer a reaper a freshly caught peeper it will delicately take it off you  and leave only works with peepers.
Now I know that stalkers like peepers and you can even tame a stalker with peepers if you really tried. (Do it. )
Haha for some reason. I don't think that it's going to work with a reaper.
But I'm going to try it. (Yaay.)
But that will come later then deep dusay. says remember to turn off power in your cyclops when you're not using it.
So it doesn't go dead. I forgot to turn off the power and I have not visited it in a while. I imagine it's dead.
and then snGaming that I should name the new ship air ass. you know bubble but, air ass that's funny
uhh, you guys pointed out something very important I've also beefed up the shrine incredibly and I've put a nice basic double bed here so that.
you know in case when I fall asleep one night I wake up and maybe just maybe I'll have a friend.
next to me in my bed and then I can wake up every morning and I can just go to sleep and look at the shrine and remember how I lost my only friend in all of Subnatica.
Ohh there it is now I can wake up to that sight to be reminded of the loss of not BUBBLEBUTT this was BUMBLEBUTT.
I got into that memorial for the wrong ship which just goes to show I'm kinda an ass hole.
But. What I got to do before that you may notice that there are a lot more lockers and everything has been beefed up.
That's because I've been farming like crazy. I've got my miscellaneous bull shit there.
I've got quartz and lead and copper, silver, gold I've got miscellaneous crystalline bullshit I've got titanium out the wazoo.
over here I've got so much crap. Why's my inventory full of piss. why's my inventory full of piss?
Wait did I leave my game open and I just started pissing my self endlessly (Probably)
Have I been dying over I, I did this farming and I thought I paused the game before
Maybe umm ok
Guess I've just been pissing my self endlessly and dying the entire time. (Not a bad way to go.)
Oh yeah, and I did record while I was farming so.. Here's a little summary of that
~Mark endlessly screaming~
It scared me- AHHHHHHH
I don't li.. I'd rather not be here
oooOOOOOOOH! Agree- HEYHEYHEYHEY
None o' that you sq- AAAAAAAY
~Scary ocean sounds~
AH!
AAAAAAAAAH
Ring around the rosy, pocket full of posy, I'M GOIN IN A BUTT HOLE AND YOUR GONNA GO SQREW YOURSELF
Sucker doesn't want the bloweys in here
And by bloweys I mean
I mean by the thing- THE THING THAT EXPOLDES
THOSE THINGS AHHHHHH
That was not a mineral deposit
oOOHH!!!
AhHH!!
HEY
Sto O Oh OH OH OHP
I just want quartz!
You know how you've got like a bunch of spiders, like in your house
You know and the only option is to burn the whole goddamn house down
You CAN'T DO THAT WITH THE OCEAN
IT'S IMMUNE
YOU CAN'T BURN IT
And that's the worst part!..
Yup Pretty much just me screaming into the void
So before we get started on the actual thing we gotta do, I gotta do something about.. all this piss
I- I guess i gotta drink it
Ahh there we go. Ahh God i need food.
(while laughing) Ahh I shouldn't a drank all tha- AHHH its NigHt! everything is going horribly wrong!
Here gimme you, I need food real bad. And I need a peeper just for... future stupidity of me.
Alright, hang on, gotta wash down all this piss with a nice ~laughing~ fishh
Ah god I like going to a pub and ordering my favourite food, fish and piss
One a you peepers, is gonna help me in my quest to get myself murdered.. which is probably gonna happen a lot sooner than I thought it might
But..
All that aside, its all good.
Oh, what is going on in there? what is that red?
Ahh! Yep. See, yeah. There's even a big arrow pointing me- You big dumb idiot! Turn off your goddamn engine! You piece of poop!
And then I don't do that, cuz I'm dumb
It's all goood, its fine. *Ship: Welcome aboard Captain* It's Fineeee
It's all fine, Im gonna cook me up some grub and its ALL fine
*disconcerting laughter*
k, non nom nom, yum yum yum *Ship: Vital signs stabilising* yum Yum Yum
Okay, Lemme put the excess peepers that I got in he-NOOo I Ate ThEm!
Piss!! Alright now I'm good I guess
Never mind! ~laughing~ I ate the peepers that i meant.. ookay
Well, I just shoved those in my gob as hard as I could.. Alright
What Im gonna do next, is I am *burp* going to.. what am I gonna do?
alright, Im gonna build bunch more solar panels. and then EvEntually, I will make a thermal plan, and use enough power transmitters to be able to get that power to my base
But thats for another episode
I don't think I'm gonna be able to get to that today, so I'm just gonna focus on improvements of my current Sitcheation (situation)
And if I can improve my current sitcheation, then im gonna be a lot HAPPIER in ma circumstance
So Imma take this copper, I'm gonna build a BUTT load more solar panels
Because thats how eco-friendly I is.
And also, these kind increase my battery bank so, iiits good its good it's all gooooooodd-bwoooopee
aaand shabooski. oh yeah, Ooh yeah. Now don't matter where da sun likez ta hide. I got all the power I need!
I didn't cheat at all! you guys saw, you guys saw for realsies.
Oh I need more titanium don't I.
*frustrated mark noise*
YEs!! Look at me! Look at THIS shit!
Look at thi- Just look at this shit!
Ya seein this? Ya seein how AWESOME I am?
ya seein that Shit!
Gah sorry about my spit! Im just so excITED
Im gonna hav- Okay that'll be where the moon pool is so I need like an observation deck here
Oh yeah, oh yeah lets get this, oh yeah, OHHHH Yeah! Thats Very Penis like! Oh yeah!
BOOM! Ive got myself a scanner room, and a lot lower integrity than I once had.
But Hey! Its me we're talking about! I didn't have integrity to begin with! So..
IS this not connecting automatically? IS thIs Not CONEcTinG AutoMatICAllY? Why is this not connecting automatically?
Y'know Im gonna assume  you're gonna connect automatically and if you don't Im gonna punch you in the dick
*inhale followed by goofy voice* Dere we go das a gud connection here *laughter* das real gud
Alright! ALrightt! ALrighT! We did it! Scoobly-Doop up that ladder! Hell yeah! Hell Yeah! Look at me now!
Look at me now! i got a real room going on. Oh look at this, look at this!
Look at all the blink blonks! Oh hell yeah
Okay, So I got that *sniff* Lets pump the seamoth back into the badboy and lets see how she dooo.
Alright. Skoodly-doo dadoodalee-Hey stalker bastard
*ship: Welcome aboard Captain* Mark: welcome abooord cyuptaiin
*Ship: All systems online* Mark: awll systeems onnlinee
So we had bubblebutt, we had bumblebutt. We've also got ass air, but to be perfectly honest I do-I'm not too *laughing* I'm not 100% too convinced about that one
I mean it's fine and all I guess but, mmm. It's fine i supooose but...
Alright I've got this, I actually had an extra one of these, surprisingly, so at least it'll give me some depth outta this thing, and I wont be completely stupid
Alright crest depth now 300! yueehh! I can die at a deeper level! Yeahhh
Okay, so what imma gonna do *chuckling* Im gonna go do the dumb thing that I said I was gonna do!
Im gon- Im gonna go do the incredibly dumb thing .. that I said I was gonna do
Im gonna dump any of this just incase, but uh. *sniff* gonna bring me a PEEPER
Imma have a peeper right-right there.
Imma put you right there. All right. Okay. All right. This is not gonna go well
*nervous giggles*
Thi- gonna say it right now, this is not gonna go well
i can`t pro-if-  If it doesnt go well Im probably not gonna respawn at the save but..
*laughter* I DONT THINK THIS IS GONNA GO THE WAY IT WAS SUGGESTING SO.. everybody blame chilliematthew if this dont work right!
Cuz I dont see how a reaper leviathans gonna gingerly take this..
*giggling* This is
Ahh im so scared *nervous laughter* This is a bad idea! Ahh god! Ahhh I dont like it! I dont like it!
AaaAaAAHH! I havent charged a reaper leviathan on foot in a long time and.. this is a BAD idea! uuahhh
*scary ocean monster sounds*
Is that the SOUND OF IT!
Uhhh, okay. All right. well... They`re somewhere around here
*splooshing water* I dunno where
*marks continued noises of fear* I-Imgt- Im so scareed
*sounds of watery death*
Hupee Peepur heres a Peepppuurr. Whoo wants a peeper. whoo doo-lee-do
Whys it look like DEATH
DARK DARK DEATH
Hee Hoo Haha Ho
heEE HWAAHAHH AHH AHH AHH
WHERE! THERE! HI HELLO... YOU WANNA PEEPER?
*Monster roaring over mark* OH GOD OH GOD TAKE THE PEEPER! It took the peeper!
*low rumbling of the ocean depths and monster grumbles fade*
It took the peeper!
*mark making caveman noises* It took the peeper!
It took the peeper... It took the peeper
it took the peeper
It took the peeper
It TOOK the PEEPER
IT Took ThE PeEpEr
*Mark Panting*
Huuuhhhh
Im gonna throw up. WHuuah- I dont feel good. I don`t feel good at all. It TooK the PEEper though! it took the peeper!
It took the peeper!
It took the peeper... Okay it took the peeper *nervous laughter*
AAahhhh. AAAAHhhhh *crying*
It toook the peepe-her-her-her
Ahh Im back in big box Barry cus I need to get these things off the wall
But mAAnnn
ooOOooh Wow
Ooh Boyy *magical music* OOOH boy I got an advanced wiring kit!
Wow. good for me.
Oh my Godd *half laughter half crying* oh god.I dont feel good
I feel-I might throw up
Ahh legitimately, I might throw up
Oh mah god
Oh man, Hey there`s t-*ominous sounds* There`s two more slots here, so thats good. Maybe theres more upgrades to be made.
For the cyclops, I think there`s a-Yeah
What other upgrades can I get?
Fire supression system. Hey, thats probably pretty good
Decoy 2 upgrade, alright
Huh, I dont like that, so, with that being said, and that new knowledge gained.. I know what I should do
I gotta go find
oof oof, I gotta go find bubble butt
Now I know bubblebutts probably broken and dead. But, if bubblebutt is still out there
Then that means, y`know, li-like out there as in, y`know bubblebutt is
In pieces but
Those pieces can be used or maybe the modules are there
I mean I cant be certain but, y`know I`ll never be
I`ll never be okay if I dont actually go
and see for myself. I`ll always wonder, I`ll always be like, man did i not do enough? Maybe bubblebutts still alive out there
I dunno, I just need,  some kind of closure so.
Im gonna go
Im gonna find. a-a-and because I`ve got this peeper trick then..
Maybe?
Maybe Maybe Maybe
Maybe Maybe
Maybe. I dunno, but maybe
So thats gotta be the next thing that I do right? Thats just...
Thats what I gotta do so, Im gonna go off. Im not even gonna take big box Barry
Cus I dont have the powe-I guess while Im gone, before I do that I should take th-the power things
And I should re-*laughter* I should turn off the engine! I should turn the engine off!
Oh yeah yeah I should. I should do that yeah okay alright
Im gonna plug these bad boys in. This is gonna suck the power right outta that but
Daylights coming so,
Hopefully that`ll be enough.Alright. Daylight coming.
I got some Peepers. I go- I got soo much piss
And i am.. Choo Choo on the train to.. deathville
Im in the vasinity. I ca-Why cant I see shit right now?
Uhh.. AHhh
I hate this. I hate this. I hate it. I know this trick works, but for some reason I..
Im willing to belive theres only like a 50/50 shot of it actually working
and th-wAHH. oh hey
I got a peeper, I gotta Peeper! (x6)
Hey! You wanna peeper? *through nervous laughter* You want a peeper buddy? You want a peeper? I got a Peeper for yoUU
I got a peeper for you. Okay, im gon` go down. youu ignore me. ooOoo okay
ANybody see, a buublebutt around here?
*quietly* anybody see the leftover corpse of the bu-UU-UU-ble bu-bu-bu Buttt
Anybanybody see pieces? Anything like that? Okay. Nobody sees pieces
Nobody sees Reeces Pieces
EeEuuu! Im so scaredd!
I know Im a lil bitch baby but god damn gimme a break here. ohh gimme a break.
Here, hit me in the face with those
eh, eh , eh , i MISSED
Thats the question right?
Cause there has to be a wreckage there would be
Even if it fell down to the bottom and rolled around it would still exist
at some point. Right?
Oh, now there's magnetite, okay, that's good.
Found magnetite.
I do need that, that's good.
Okay, got that!
Oh, hey, Warpy-Woo...
That's just normal wreckage.
I think, anyway.
Hard to say.
Time capsule?
Whoa!
What the hell?
Wha?
*voice: (??) Blueprint acquired*
Huh?
Oh, a beacon!
Aah!
Aahey!
God damn it, you cock ass!
Get outta here!
Get outta here, you shit!
It wouldn't have just vanished,
it wouldn't have, that's not how it works.
When it breaks, if it breaks,
like, it breaks into pieces.
That's the thing.
Ho! Hey! Ha! Hoo!
You wanna Pee-pee?
You wanna Peeper?
(Nervous Peeper stuttering)
BOOORRR!
*beep beep, 30 seconds*
Aah!
That's a problem!
Oh! That's a problem!
Ohh! That's a problem!
I HATE everything
I hate everything
Everything
I hate it
I hate it, I hate it so much.
(laughing) I hate it!
(crying noises)
I KNOW!
KAREN!
I'm aware!
Okay, alright, I got a Pee-pee
I got a Pee-pee
Fallen into pieces, he couldn't have carried it that far.
What's that?
Naw, come on, you were th- ah, you were something!
What are you?
What is this?
Oh!
I pissed myself, but wow!
An alien vent!
This is the, uh-
don't. Ah, you son of a tit!
Data downloads for the alien vent, okay, alright.
(softly) God dammit.
Alien vent... Yeah.
That's right, it's-
That's what's leading to the Sea Emperor's chambers.
Where'd you put Bubblebutt?
Where'd you put him?
Uh, puh-pee-per
Uh-oh.
Uh, ah, terrifying! Terrifying!
Horrible! Horrible! Horrible! Horrible! Horrible!
Hah!
Horrible!
You want another? I got another.
I just so happen to have more.
Psshhaaahhh! Horrible!
Horrible!
Ho-okay, I'm out!
I'm outtie!
I'm out!
This is a bad idea!
Bad idea, I'm running out of Peepers.
Okay, I'm out, I'm outtie, I'm outtie nine thousand
Ho! Woah! Ho! Woah! Woah! Hey!
Woah-woah!
Ho! Heh!
Hey! Hi! Uhh, howdy neighbor!
How're you doing? Umm...
Could you not fly that close to my base, that is NOT okay.
Okay!
Oh! Alright, were back!
We're back, we're back, we're back
We're back from that horrible,
Horrible adventure. Why did i do that?
Why?... Why? (giggles)
Why? Why did I do that?
I do not know
Okay
Let's make a computer chip
Why? Why? Why?
I'm gonna build the vehicle upgrade bay...
...And look at these
These bad boys are SO FULL of power
Im gonna take that
Im gonna build a- what do I need for a computer chip?
I need table coral. Thats just it!
Alright! Then thats what I will go get
So I`ll be right back
Alright vehicle upgrade station, BOOM!
Boom baby boom baby boom baby boom baby BoOOm!
So I know what I need to do,
I need to get the materials to be able to build some more, uh, efficiency things
The depth module. I need to do that in the modification station I got back in the cyclops
But before I do any of that
It is time
to name
this new thing
and I think before I do that, I have to get the colour right.
y`know
i-I just have to get the colour. Wai- Hang on.
Lets get a look at her
oooOH Shes beautifullll
ooh shes beaUTIfull
Imma call her..
Bubblegum
*Karen: Calorie intake recommended*
I take that as agreement Karen
ooOOh youre just saying you could EAT Bubblegum up Karen
(laughing) Ahh thats so cutee
Ahhh Thats SOO cutee :)
Well..
Everybody say hi to Bubblegum
Tha- That lettering is not showing up as bright as I want it to
C`mon, wheres the brIGHtness?
Wheres the bright bright?
Gimme the bright bright.
I guess thats gonna have to do
Alright, everybody say hi to BubbleGum
Now BUBBLEGUM and I
Are gonna go on a lot of adventures
and Im gonna take care of you BubbleGum!
Dont worry!
(laughing) Until- Dont worry about what happened to BumbleButt and BubbleButt before you.
But BubbleGum
We`re gonna go places
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Everybody say hi to BubbleGum here
Lemme know what you think down in the comments below
And if you have any advice and or jokes to make at my expense, let me know aswell. I might put you on a locker
So thank you again!
And as always, I will see you..
IN the next video
BUH BYE!!! :DD
*OUTRO MUSIC*